apparently in business school
they don't teach you how to operate a
toaster oven
because some smart sexy temp left his
cheese pita
an oven instead of timing it for the
toaster thing
wow okay well i guess they don't teach
how to operate a toaster oven in
business that's exactly what i said hey
did you miss that day
there ryan are you absolutely toast
heaven 101 you failed i'm so sorry
i have it song attention everyone that i
want to sing
that i wrote especially for this
occasion when i was up there among the
flames
ready ryan started the fire
it was always burning since the world
returning
ryan started the fire it was always
nixon foreign television north korea
south korea maryland monroe
ryan started the fire
[Music]
you take a running leap and you learn
[Applause]
[Music]
in the wind ladies and gentlemen
mr duke silver
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
is
unbreak my heart
say you love me again
you know what i like this song this hurt
that you
can't shut up
the nerve unbelievable
cried so many
just smile for me and let the day begin
you are the sunshine that
lights my heart with air
secrets stolen
from deep inside you know the song
already of course i do everyone knows
the song it's amazing
the drum beats out of time if you're
lost you can look and you will find me
time after time if you fall i will catch
you
oh i'll be waiting time
after time after time
time after time
good stuff this never happened
oh hey guys what's up you want to join
our acapella jam circle
oh no are you guys harry potter fans i
do not like where this is going three
four
won't you come visit hogwarts
i'll be alone
[Music]
this is actually pretty funny you got to
know harry potter
oh my god something's happening
9986 000 minutes
we actually sat down and did the math
986 000 minutes
that's how many minutes that you've
worked here
in costumes and impressions in meetings
in cups of coffee for birthdays
more meat exams email forwards you made
us read
9 000 986 000 minutes
that's like watching die hard 80 000
times
you hit me with your car you helped me
get off drugs
i watch you when you sleep i forgive you
for kissing me
[Music]
measure your life
[Music]
[Music]
yeah okay
well this is gonna hurt like a mother
okay here's the situation your parents
went away on a week's vacation
they left the keys to the brand-new
porsche but they mine
well of course not i'll just take you
for a little spin
and maybe show it off to a couple of
friends
i'll just cruise around the neighborhood
well maybe i shouldn't yeah of course i
should
pay attention here's the thick of the
plot i pulled up to the corner at the
end of my block that's when i saw this
beautiful girly girl walking i picked up
my car phone
to perpetrate like i was talking
sunroof was open the music was high and
that girl's hand was steadily moving up
my thigh she had opened up three buttons
on her shirt so far
i guess that's why i didn't notice that
police car i can't believe it i made a
mistake
my parents are the same no matter time
nor place so to all your kids all across
the land
no need to argue parents just don't
understand all right
thank you thank you just a little
something i know
so what's up uh someone is on fire and
rams at park they need you to get down
there right away
oh my god so do you recognize any of
these men
i was hiding in the bathroom stall so i
didn't see his face but
i heard him he was singing along to the
music at the bar do you remember what he
was singing i think it was that song
i want it that way backstreet boys i'm
familiar okay
number one could you please sing the
opening to i want it that way really
okay you are
my fire
number two keep it going the one desire
number three believe when i
say number four i wanted that away
tell me why ain't nothing
i never wanna hear you say
[Applause]
ah chills literal chills it was number
five
number five killed my brother oh my god
i forgot about that part
you